hey so if you don't know my guest today
his name is wonton tat here's who knows
my guest today every world leader knows
my guest today wonton tad it doesn't
matter if it's russia if it's china if
it's north korea definitely us canada
iran ukraine italy australia everybody
knows him and his technology clear view
ai which
it's pissed some people off some people
like it some people are uncomfortable
with it i think you guys just got tagged
with a fine from italy australia told
you to stay out of their way i called a
few different people who are my friends
in the cia or fbi and different kind of
government institutions and it's so
funny the kind of feedback i got about
your organization and yourself there
were those who said
pat
don't let the media fool you they are
necessary meaning you are necessary uh
we we are eventually going to be doing
this whether we like it or not this is
the direction we're going and then there
was another side that said don't let him
and some people fool you we have to be
very careful with this because this is
ultimately 1984.
big brother's watching that's kind of
where they're at you know
he may be a nice guy but what if a guy
with power really takes it over and has
negative motors etc etc so having said
that uh one thing i do respect is the
fact that you decided to come here live
for an interview so i appreciate you for
taking the time and thanks pat for
having me on what an introduction well
no you i've been following your photo
for a while i've been following your
story and what you've done uh for a
while so for the audience who doesn't
know
who you are and what you're doing what
clear view ai is once you take a minute
and give a background on clearview sure
uh so
the way i like to describe clearview ai
it's like a google for faces so it's a
search engine but instead of putting in
words when you type someone's name or
any kind of information you upload a
photo of someone's face and everything
in the database that you find is
publicly available so the three biggest
misperceptions about clearview ai in
terms of what it does one is it searches
private data none of the information
that we're searching is private it's all
uh publicly available anything you can
find in a google search the second thing
is that it's a real-time surveillance
right so
um this is actually used after the fact
so after a crime has been committed
then you will run a photo through the
search engine and a lot of controls in
place uh that ensure that law
enforcement are using it you know for
after the fact investigations and the
third you know misconception is
that
people would take a photo do a match and
make an arrest there's a lot more that
goes into the technology and also the
process that law enforcement use it for
before they make any kind of arrest or
search warrant or anything like that
so you can see how that may concern some
people like the other absolutely yeah so
what what are some of the common
concerns you're seeing and the pushback
from the app because you were you had
you got to see some assists from who let
me see google youtube uh linkedin and
there was one other one that put a vimeo
i think put a cease and desist on you
but that's just a cease and desist
stop doing what you're doing uh
australia even said i can read what
australia said and then italy put the
fine
why are companies like google linkedin
vimeo youtube why is australia why is
italy why are so many organizations
afraid of what clearview ei does
so it's an honor to be at the center of
the debate so i think what we created
was something actually new it hadn't
been done before and any new technology
from the printing press even the word
processor has controversy when it comes
out because people aren't sure what the
implications are going to be of it and
so our job is to really kind of educate
people on how it's really used and all
that kind of stuff and when it comes to
um you know
the people who are the detractors we've
seen a lot of them move over
to our side over time but with major
events like the capital riots where
we're instrumental in helping id people
and now in the situation in ukraine uh
but fundamentally like you said a lot of
people who use our technology in law
enforcement they really love it um and
they say they can't do without it so
some of these agencies especially
federal ones solving crimes against
children they've said without clear of
uai there are so many cases of child
molesters that would have never been
caught or children who wouldn't have
been saved so i'd rather live in a world
where our customers really love us and
they would actually do so much for us
and we really love them as well and hear
those kind of stories and be you know
somewhat misunderstood by the rest as
opposed to the opposite
and i get the idea that sometimes when a
new company comes in they disrupt so for
example let's just do facial recognition
we were all uncomfortable with facial
recognition but what percentage of apple
users when they log on to their iphone
use facial recognition most of them
that's not the security code right right
and i i know what you're saying well
radio or you know a printer or fax or
whatever that for xerox whatever these
guys came but the reason why i feel this
makes certain people feel uncomfortable
is because
we
are losing control of our lives and the
decision making where someone's watching
every move i want to read an email you
wrote to your employees this year i
think this was january 18th
of 20th this is public so it's not like
anybody can read it i'm sure you're
comfortable with it so this email you
wrote to them you said clearview ai was
known as a startup until new york times
put us on their front page in january
2020 we were only a tiny company at the
time with only 10 employees barely 10
employees i was unprepared for intense
pressure both personally and
professionally that would be typically
reversed for multi-billion dollar
reserve for multi-billion auto
corporation i weathered those days by
remaining focused on a mission i share
with all of you to make this world a
safer place our mission to make this
world a safer place it is a miracle we
survived today we have 45 full-time
employees
we serve 3 100 law enforcement agencies
around the united states and we are
still alive and thriving clearly to ai
technology was used to help identify
many of capital riders january 6th we
hired an experienced executive team a
stellar advisory board and a crack legal
team raised another 30 million dollars
in venture financing we were selected as
a time 100 most influential company last
year our algorithm has ranked as the
most accurate in the u.s and western
world number two worldwide by nist
plotting putting to bed any concerns
around accuracy and racial bias today
the internet is used to commit all kinds
of crimes such as sex trafficking
financial fraud and money laundering big
tech companies resist
working with government to help those
end crimes advocacy groups etc etc and
you continue to say the difference
between us and others so you know in
just one year uh in just one field
office with a federal agency clearview
ai technology has resulted in the rest
of 60c 66 child abusers and rescue 103
children we can go on and on and talk
about a lot of the good that's doing
okay
so facial recognition i think was first
introduced in a movie deja vu with
denzel washington when he says what's
that oh we have facial recognition no
way you know here's how we can catch a
bad guy that's pretty crazy remember
deja vu i don't know you know what's
funny i didn't actually grow up on tv
until i was about 14. so i got to go
watch dad you're kidding me you've never
seen it and i got to watch about face
what was it what's the one with uh
nicholas cage what is that i don't know
what oh yeah uh uh uh i don't know which
one that is you're not my face off right
face off yeah i gotta watch these movies
but anyway well that's good that your
parents didn't keep you from uh watching
the movies you i'm assuming you were
doing more reading than watching movies
we had a lot of books and we got the
internet when i was 10 and that's how i
got obsessed with computers and
programming so let's talk about that
because you know you started a company
at 21 years old which was called what
happy happy or something like that it
was earlier yeah it not too that he was
in you were 21 years old maybe even
younger than yeah
19 years old and you got all the way up
to i don't know i saw some of the apps
together 10 million downloads on apple
ios and then eventually cops showed up
knocking on your door saying
tell us the story with what happened
with that uh uh technology
well that was a long time ago but when
um i was a kid i was loving um
programming right i was obsessed with
computers so i would stay home from high
school and watch mit video lectures on
computer programming and so that was my
outlet that's how i learned a lot of
things and my
family kind of indulged that they let me
do it
and when i was younger i was like oh
this is uh silicon valley san francisco
is a place where a lot of startup
companies happen in australia where i
grew up it wasn't as cool to do a
startup and it was still 2007 so i went
to visit just to see what it was like
and i met some great people uh who ended
up being investors and in 07 it was some
of the first facebook apps so you'd make
quiz games and all these different games
that people would play and it was really
cool because i got to do the thing i
like to do which is create stuff so i'm
very creative i love programming i love
designing things and so that was a great
outlet for that it was kind of
entrepreneurial part was secondary to it
um and yeah made a lot of things that
were viral and same when the iphone
first came out made a lot of top iphone
games so in total we had like 20 or 30
different games and different apps and
along the way um all kinds of stuff
happened yeah got it so if i was in high
school with you 10th grade 11th grade
who were you in high school
i was pretty quiet and i had like a guy
with like two or three friends you were
the quiet kid yeah you were you were
genius you were smart you knew what you
were doing with coding building stuff
yeah but i was more independent right so
sometimes i wouldn't get the best grades
because i just love to do my own thing a
little bit
anti-authoritarian right
like
if some you know to get me to do
something you tell me not to do it like
half the time yeah then i would be
interested in it but if there was too
much pressure i'd say you know what
what's the point you know so then you
know what that makes me think about it
it makes me think about
um you know for me so i'm uh
i'm i'm big on capitalism right i'm big
on free enterprise free market so then
you go deeper and you say why well i was
raised in iran so who cares what does
that have to do with capitalism raising
iran i won free speech every time i said
something i got in trouble
and then i come to america i want to
make the kind of money i want to make i
don't want you to stop me from doing it
and other people are trying to tell me
what to do control me regulation all
this other stuff it led me to want to
start a company with a mission statement
of bringing back the free enterprise
system and hope to american families
right that's what drove me
to start a company like clearviewai
you can wake up and do many different
things if you know how to code
you can decide to compete against a
twitter and create a twitter
using the cryptocurrency and blockchain
technology and go a different route
there's many different routes why
did you choose to build something like
clearview ai where's the motive for that
yeah it's a great question and it's very
interesting what you said about free
enterprise and things like that i think
it's very important and i think what
makes america great is it can take
people who are a little rebellious and
channel that energy into making really
great companies and providing value so i
think
the us as a as a system as an
entrepreneurial system
gets really gets the best out of people
and that's what's really impressive
about it even when you compare it to
other you know western countries but
what came my motivation's always been
technology so again when i was a kid
mit had their video lectures on lisp and
scheme programming which is very
esoteric stuff which i loved and so i
was always looking at different
programming languages and how to build
things and then when i was in san
francisco i ended up moving to new york
city traveling around and i had a fair
amount of spare time and you don't
really know what to do and part of the
time i was looking at the advances in ai
so i saw imagenet which is a competition
for recognizing things in images is this
a computer is this a plant is this a dog
or a cat and the results got really good
and then i looked at facial recognition
and i would read papers so google had
facebook both had uh deep learning
papers on facial recognition i said hey
can i get this working on my computer
and we ended up getting it working and
what we realized was getting more data
to train the algorithm to make it
accurate across all ethnicities iranian
people black people white people brown
people that was really key to improving
performance
and so it was really tinkering around
and seeing that there was a big gap
there it was great to get it working and
then it was next step was finding use
cases i mean i never thought i'd be
selling to law enforcement be honest
right 3 100 agents yeah plus yeah and um
so
what happened was we made this really
great technology and we were pitching
different ideas would it work for
building access would it work for you
know hospitality the iphone just came
out with uh face id would have worked
for and and there was some demand there
people liked it but when we gave it to
law enforcement they came back the next
week and said we got like 20 cases we
solved
and then we came in we looked at looked
at them and sometimes
they didn't even look that similar but
it was the same guy and so these were
cash out scams so people would say hey
my name is
joe smith and my social was blah blah
blah i need a new debit card or i need
to withdraw you know ten thousand
dollars in cash and the teller would say
hey show me your id and the id would
have their face and all the information
and so for the first time they were able
to take the face of the criminal who
impersonated someone else and find them
on social media
on a previous arrest and that was
phenomenal the next week they called up
and said we've identified a
person who's been talking to a 12 year
old girl so that kind of like impact was
much better than anything else we could
have thought of did you think about that
pre-starting the company like let me go
catch the bad guy or was it more
let's find a better way to
you know
create a company that's not out there
because you know it's sometimes guys sit
around the smartest guys in silicon
valley will sit around sit around and
say you know like the paypal mafia you
know um let's go compete in this market
we can beat them and we just use a blue
ocean strategy you know minimize
increase decrease eliminate you know
create all this that's what we're gonna
do let's go after this industry let's go
after that industry was it one of those
things where you and your friends sat
there and said how about if we go after
these guys or was it somebody a bad guy
did something to you and your family
said i'm gonna go go catch every one of
these bad guys ever what was the
motivation
the original motive again is technology
and making it work so once we got it to
work islamic technology it was amazing
and once we found law enforcement as but
do you understand what i'm asking yes so
business strategy is part of it yeah but
i don't have as much of a business
background as a tech background right so
once we've figured out law enforcement's
there it's very clear there's a lot of
agencies you can make a lot of money but
there's no other motivation like there
wasn't like a correcting an injustice
catching a bad guy you know it's
well there's definitely a lot of crime
in san francisco
nothing personal okay but uh i mean i
lived in san francisco for eight years
and it's definitely declined ever since
i when i left i didn't think it could
get any worse so what's important to me
is things that are in the public
interest right so uh you know living in
new york city was
kind of
great because it was more than one
subway line things worked a lot better
and i got to meet a lot of people who
used to be in new york city government
and were
and i think that they're fantastic
especially people in the nypd so
we're always thinking
about it's very
when you're starting something new right
it can be very nebulous right especially
if you have a technology but the theme
of facial recognition if there was a
theme to it it's about safety and
security right you can unlock your phone
with facial recognition
id checks are done with facial
recognition these are all things done in
an opt-in way and then you also have
something like clear view which can be
also for safety which is searching a
database
to identify someone who's unknown right
so we're always thinking about safety
and security we never even though i
spent my
earlier part of my career doing consumer
internet we couldn't really think of a
use case there right so so this started
off this started off wanting to mainly
use what you work with government
agencies right you got 3 100 of them
when did cole walmart mba the other guys
show up
sure so we only sell to government
agencies we do not sell to private
entities but in the beginning uh what
happened was
it spread by word of mouth once some of
the first agency used they then said hey
they told the neighboring agencies we
would call them we'd sign them up we'd
say if you get some success let us know
and we can you know try and go to
procurement and
along the way all these other private
entities like bank of america and you
know retail and but mainly banks they uh
would collaborate with law enforcement
so some of the misperception is hey are
they using it in real time which they
don't but they would use it uh at the
time for uh investigations after the
fact so again that uh impersonation
example with bank of a uh with uh
someone going into a bank banks would
also need to identify people and they
had former law enforcement work for them
so it's the same technology uh used in
that way and then out of uh
sense of simplicity right we just said
hey we're just going to deal with the
government make it very clear because
there was a lot of people asking
questions a lot of pressure and i think
that was the right choice to just focus
on the u.s and
government agencies like do you mind
showing everybody technology how it
works i know you you just you guys took
a picture of me and two of our employees
okay okay i'm curious to know so the
audience can see this as well uh uh
jorge if we can go to it so the audience
can know exactly how this is being used
by the 3100 different uh organizations
so um this is what they normally see
their workflow here we've
improved the um
design okay so you put in a case number
before you do an investigation so in
this case we'll have call it
something like that
that allows administrators whoever runs
the program to
see what the searches are so they see
anything inappropriate they can remove
that person uh as access to clearview
the second part
is
they look for a pod uh look for a file
these are not jpeg files and they're not
uploading so
uh you needed to be jpeg yeah
okay i can um i can resume later once we
get it you want me to get the guys to
get a jpeg file yes okay why don't we do
that so uh if you guys uh
if you guys can can they take those
pictures and convert it to jpeg yeah
okay real quick and then what would you
like them to do just bring it in and dr
drop it to you yep okay so why don't you
convert it to jpeg bring it here i'm
actually really curious to know what
pictures comes up and what you pull up
we're going to do mine by the way just
to see what happens when we test mine i
mean now i'm in your system once we do
this then we got a couple other guys
just to be curious when this is taking
place you ever seen the movie minority
report i know you're not a movie guy
i actually watched it oh yeah you
watched minority report maybe four or
five years ago yeah so in minority
report there's do we have the scene from
minority report do we by any chance of
the scene from minority report uh uh
tyler if you can pull up the scene from
minority report you know which one i'm
talking about
just to show there is a scene in
minority report
where they break into this place they
break the window and it's tom cruise
obviously in the movie they break into
this place they break the window
they go in there and then they come in
and they arrest this guy i don't know if
you know the scene and the scene says
we are here to arrest you on a future
crime you're going to commit yeah okay
so i'm getting arrested based on motive
and a future crime right
now
we all know certain things takes steps
to get there right like before you know
a lot of people that are capitalists are
afraid of going to communism before you
get to communism first come socialism
then you go to full control then you
have full control right if you know uh
some people are afraid hey don't touch
my second amendment i want to be able to
have my second amendment first you start
off with
a you know you know let's just say uh ak
for whatever certain weapons you take
then you work your way towards taking a
gun it's like ground so people are a
little paranoid saying this is kind of
one which is normal only the paranoid
survive
some people are sitting here saying so
you're going to be able to do facial
recognition on me
and let's say you're a nice guy what
makes a thing the next guy that's going
to come or buy you over and he cuts you
two billion dollar check and you take
that check and you say i just built a
company to you know become financially
free my dreams become a reality but the
next guy that buys it says yes let's use
this
to go find out everything and add
additional
searches on the computer that this
person is doing to see if we can lead to
a potential future crime that's about to
happen then we can use that to arrest
people for crime that they weren't going
to create but we have to trust the
system telling us and i'm asking an
advanced technical question what are
your thoughts about the concern people
have with that i think there's a lot of
concerns and they come from you know a
lot of the media that's happened around
like minority report or other kind of
movies that are you know subconscious
and they you know speak to a lot of
fears that people have uh in reality
what uh where the exact opposite we're
used after the crimes happen so there's
nothing about pre-crimes but you can
advance like you can how do you yeah how
do you know if something's going to
happen i get that what i'm saying is and
then we have also live in a great legal
system right and i think that's what's
interesting right we have presumption of
innocence you have to prove as an
investigator that uh you know uh and
then you have to prove beyond a reason a
lot of people have been in jail that
didn't do anything that's also true but
also and in a lot of those cases come
down to things like eyewitness testimony
right so innocence project has said 70
of people in jail that they exonerate
that are in there 70 of them come from
eyewitness testimony right if you had a
technology like facial recognition you
can make that a thing of the past where
instead of eye eyewitness lineup and you
had a photo of the crime scene you can
actually find the real person if it's
accurate or you can exonerate people so
i think some of that comes to the
misperception of like how the legal
system works and investigations work and
there's a lot it's been an honor for me
to see how law enforcement actually work
these cases and granted there are some
who are not uh the best but for the most
part most of them that i've met have
been absolutely fantastic and they take
this because it's a division of
responsibilities they you know do the
investigations then you have a judicial
system so you have a lot of checks and
balances in our systems unless those go
away then that's the problem whereas if
you see other countries who are more
authoritarian like china and russia they
do apply it in a real-time manner and
that's a world i don't want to live in
uh yeah
they openly showed but i don't know if
you i'm sure you've seen it they show
their technology and they say we're
pretty much skynet you know the movie
skynet skynet is uh i haven't seen it
but not not the movies kind of thing
i have tornado one and two okay great so
this guy is like hey we're here to
protect the world and we're here to
protect people and then the reality of
it is no skynet eventually turns evil so
where china's like no we have skynet but
it's a it's a it's a nice scenario i saw
the i saw the video something got lost
in translation he's like oh yeah it's
nice
they have a different system right like
they can detain people for absolutely no
reason in china right or whatever reason
they want to for indefinite amount of
time and that real-time monitoring is
something i don't believe in uh that you
should do on maths you don't remember
yes you don't believe in and i'll leave
yeah and i do think that
what is interesting is society and
technology co-evolve right so you just
can't take that technology and apply it
the same way here it just wouldn't work
in on many levels and what we did is we
thought about how can we make our system
better right so if there's probable
cause right
if the crime has been committed and all
you have is a photo then they run it
through the system
and then they look at the results and
then they try and make the
identification one great example is
and it's also on our website in our
video is we got a call in 2019 from
homeland security and this is a good
example because it shows how they
actually do investigations and how
powerful it can be and also how it's
done responsibly right um
and there was a video of a child abuser
abusing a six-year-old girl and selling
it on the dark web
this is why our customers are very
passionate about keeping the technology
and making sure
it's used properly
this six year was being abused and in
that video for just two or three frames
it was an adult face in the background
kind of blurry with a beard they put him
through the system at the time
with three billion images there was only
one result he was in the background of
someone else's instagram photo just
working this trade show
for supplements so there's no name
attached to him they could click the
link and they had a location in vegas
and so they could find from the photo
that he worked at a certain uh
place
and they could call the employer find
more information from the employer
and then question him and corroborate
the child pornography he was selling and
his house and
photos on facebook that he had of his
house
in the background and he's with 35 years
in jail so that shows that when a search
result comes up it's just a clue it's
just a lead it's and every photo in the
database is a clue so it's how you use
it and i don't think that uh things like
pre-crime that have suggested in you
know minority report would even be legal
in this kind of system that we have
today you don't think it'll be legal in
this country well you'd have to
you know you have to prove that they
violated something i totally get it but
to trust that the government will not
manipulate to get rid of somebody just
the other day the president said and on
stage that we have to you know
get rid of this the leader and he's
talking about putin and they came back
and they took it back and now that's not
what right really meant that's not what
really he really meant there's motives
that the government has and they can
figure out a way to take somebody down
if they want to there's many many
different ways
to do that they'll create new laws to go
after a
new person the ricoh change many many
different things have changed
to go after somebody i'm not concerned
about you i'm concerned about who gets a
hold of this technology and takes it to
the next level who would have thought
you know 10 years ago a content creator
is going to be censored who would have
thought 10 years ago a president is
going to be censored but can you imagine
20 years ago saying you know what
clinton is saying is so out of control
we have to silence him can you imagine
40 years ago or 50 years ago silencing
kennedy because what he's saying against
somebody like that's ridiculous but
we're living in that phase so the speed
of advance advancement today
what would be
10 years
50 years ago is being done in one year
today so people are trying to catch up
so for example the government formats
imperialism
or monarchy
you have one ruler uh
that does very well louis the whatever
you know and then comes the next one he
doesn't he takes the empire and uses his
power to abuse the people then the next
one comes has to clean up his mess and
the next one comes is the same as the
other guy so whoever's in charge can
typically
turn a good technology into bad
technology that's the concern with a lot
of people yeah so i'm not really worried
about you but it sure looks like we're
headed towards the directional minority
report don't you think
i really don't think so i think this
future is for us to make right and
we're the only company that has this
large database we decided to only serve
law enforcement with it for the reason
is that there's controls on what they do
and what they use it for right
and they they're playing a certain role
to investigate crimes and help solve
them and um and then you know we don't
think this database is appropriate for
you know everyone's case
let's let's see let's see what's
interesting topic but yeah all i can say
is uh
having seen how they use it and what
they use it for and the success stories
we get every day about saving children
and all this really good stuff it's hard
for me to say that it's a net negative i
think overall it's in that positive and
a lot of the concerns that people have
had and that are legitimate still are in
the theoretical stages i i contribute to
multiple
charities that go after human
trafficking and i support that but for
us to think that somebody gets a hold of
this to use it in a different way that
the motive's not going to be there i
think it's nice for us to think that
anyway but it's important and we also
vet all our customers we on board we
have the ability to turn off the
customers we vet too much of government
agencies though how do you vet them well
um yeah if we hear that yeah their their
accountability is the government they
don't have to tell you nothing
they they're they they we we can go into
a little more but i hear your concerns
and i think i i think that's what's
great about being on your show is to you
know talk about these issues well i
respect the fact that you have the
audacity to sit down and have these
conversations but that that is a
that is a common concern i hear from a
lot of that is um
a photo of you what a friendly looking
guy right there yeah he couldn't even
smile
what
what investigator would do is like if
that was uh as part of a crime
investigation
run a search and see
uh
you know
any information so we just confirm that
photo okay and now it's searching over
20 billion images on the open internet
so these are all things that are
uh open so if you want me to click on a
photo to see more
uh you you do
that photo
so how different is this than google
images
well it's google images doesn't search
based on faces you can go to type the
name in and look at images
so you know that case that is uh
investigating that uh child pornographer
in is in the background of another photo
he didn't tag himself in that so i'm
glad you guys got joker in the back by
the way that's the best joker heath
ledger yeah
so how many how many pictures came up
how many pictures are you seeing you
come up
99 results there are more but like we
have our system cut off at a certain
point okay so let's just say i am
working for an agency so what do i do
now so for example you might be in uh
say this was a criminal investigation
where you're trying to identify a
suspect sometimes it's a victim too so
uh you know especially in child uh
pornography cases they don't know who
the victims are you're trying to find a
name of a person right so uh in this
case
uh can i click on that one sure
this goes to a website and that website
might have information about the name so
here we can see that your name patrick
that david
and it's you know
an instagram profile so this is
who that is that's actually britney
kaiser who was a whistleblower for
cambridge analytica yeah i don't know if
you're familiar with her i've heard of
cambridge analytica so let's do let's do
a couple of other guys that we have here
so
um
we'll see
so google for faces okay
kai good for you guys these guys got a
nice smile from norway how do you not
love that guy
and thanks to kai for volunteering yeah
thank you kai tyler again it's only
anything that's out there um that's
public
kai you're officially in the system just
so you know
well all the photos that are uploaded
don't get added it's only searching the
other systems let's see what comes oh
you got a picture right there when he
was younger top right
okay this is us
but if you go to
all right
keep going do that again who is this kai
what are you doing does that appear
okay oh my gosh kai
all right so let's uh uh
yeah that's starting to really concern
me that picture right there we gotta
have a conversation with kai yeah well
yeah in the context of uh you know
investigation for law enforcement you're
just trying to id someone right yeah or
also verify who it is say is you have an
eyewitness lineup right things like that
this can be a way more accurate way to
id people
and so that's how the system works in a
nutshell so if you take this context of
uh you know someone robbed a bank right
uh someone shot somebody and all there
is is video footage and you don't have a
name yeah you know i wouldn't use this
tool and this data set so i think that's
the part that people miss a little bit
we have to dig into the context around
it um and so
and we think there's a lot of great
applications of facial recognition that
are protective of consumers that are
opt-in right what if when you signed up
for your bank account you opted in to
have your photo so whenever there's a
large transaction at ten thousand
dollars or more that it does a facial
recognition check so i think there's two
sides to the technology uh and that
side's a the less controversial one um
and that's a great way to prevent why
why is the majority of the world okay
with all the other stuff but now with
what not with what you're doing like why
are people okay with going to the bank
take a picture hey can we do this sure
hey i'm going to go get my id dmv takes
a picture or whatever i go to this place
that's fine why are why are people
comfortable with that but so many are
not comfortable with you well i think
there's two parts of the innovation one
is the law the size of the data set
right uh that was 20 billion images and
20 billion you were just at three
billion you guys are at 20 billion three
there were 10 now at 20 years holy moly
from the open internet um and so in this
context every photo is a potential clue
to you know exonerate someone
help solve a crime uh and so i think
that's part of it and it's really
accurate now i if you look at the
history of facial recognition in 2011
2012 facebook had tagged your friends
but they only have to be accurate one
out of a thousand you might have a
thousand friends on facebook then apple
did unlocking your phone but that's only
matching the same photo and what we were
able to do was search millions or
billions of photos accurately because
the more um that's a harder problem to
do so i think those are the two things
that made people more concerned um and
we're living in a time now where
technology companies were very beloved
in the 2010s right google and facebook
they couldn't do anything wrong and i
think rightly so that a lot of people
now have a more critical eye towards
technology especially big tech right so
let's look at some places where this
would make all of us honest you think
you think both democrats and
republicans and independents would love
to have a technology where you get to
vote with facial recognition well that's
the if you wanted to add more
controversy to something controversial
then yeah i think
that would make everybody else i think
uh
in theory people all want to have
free and fair elections right uh and but
um you know that's something we're not
uh
gonna do
if that makes any sense so everyone
you're not gonna do yeah our company's
not focused on that right but it's
election integrity and that stuff is
uh key for both uh democrats and
republicans um and that would change the
game if where a lot of people would
probably be good for that some may not
be well it depends on how you do it
right like where does the data go what
would you do you could theoretically
design a system where
all it does is detect if a duplicate
person voted and throw out the data and
it's not tied to your voting record and
all that kind of stuff so there are
there are ways and discussions of people
doing it on the blockchain
but you know the political process is
slow and very state dependent and things
like that and i think there'd be some
misinterpretation
of intentions around it but i do think
that what's interesting uh when it comes
to crime is there's a lot of different
crimes where people impersonate others
or they make fake ids or synthetic fraud
right tons of that happening and they're
using different names and they're using
different emails and phone numbers
burner phones to commit crime mainly
financial crimes uh but it's
really hard to change your face and so
this kind of world you can actually
prevent a lot of crime from happening
and um i think it makes things safer
overall for everybody you think we're
going to
in a direction where we're no longer
going to need to have a wallet like not
at all an id a passport because you're
going to go to the airport and they're
just going to see you yeah that's him
yeah he's good yeah that's good
i think in an opt-in way i think that
it's a possibility opt-in away yeah so
you might say to yourself and go to the
airport and say all right there's a the
manual check line and there's a line i
when i was at home i signed up for an
app put my photo in and i can just walk
through so i think that is a possibility
for future i think it's
a lot cooler than the metaverse when you
think about it um a lot cooler than the
metaverse yeah tell me why well the
metaverse seems to me like everyone's
living in vr and uh you know living
trying to avoid reality if that makes
any sense so you know with covet and
lockdowns we're just you know excited to
get back to normal it's great to be here
in person right
and especially living in new york
because that's like that was the new
year's a lot better now yeah i hear it's
getting i hear it's getting back to
you know you know in the right direction
which is good kyrie irving pushed
the mayor together so shout out to kyrie
for
staying strong so let's talk about what
italy did and then we'll go into
australia as well so sure let's first do
italy this is march 9th italy slaps
facial recognition uh firm
clearview ai with a 20 million dollar
fine
uh italy's data privacy watchdog said it
will find the controversial facial
recognition from clear uei for breaching
eu iran investigation by italy's data
protection authority found that the
company's database of 10 billion images
of faces
includes those of italians and residents
in italy the new york city-based firm is
being fined 20 million and will also
have to delete any facial biometrics it
holds of italian nationals this isn't
the first time that the uh beleaguered
facial recognition tech company is
facing uh is facing legal consequences
the
uk
data protection authority last november
fined the company 22 million dollars
after finding its practices which
included collecting selfies of people
without their consent from security
camera footages or mock shots violate
the nation's data protection laws the
company also has been banned in sweden
france and australia
that's a lot of countries that are not
happy with you
yeah well you know what's upset you know
but heartbreaking about this stuff is we
had in 2019 some law enforcement
agencies just use a demo of that
software
about software to help solve crimes
against children um and i think it's a
bit of a overreaction from uh a lot of
detractors when the first story about
clearview ai came out but our legal
team's handling it we got a great legal
team um and we don't do any business in
the eu so
you know there's no
you know jurisdictional argument for
that and again the legal team is
handling it i think
um
they're
overdone um the maximum fine in you know
gdpr should only be four percent of
total total revenues um four percent of
total that's what the law says right and
you know they've gone um overboard and
um but you know the hardware part per
case no no that's a total max but anyway
my point is again i'm not the legal team
so i shouldn't be talking about that
that's what i'm asking my point is
let me ask this question here so just
for my own if my only reason to know
this as a guy that runs businesses is it
four percent
total or four percent italy four percent
australia four percent xyz where you
know if a hundred countries do it could
be four hundred percent
yes okay i got you yeah okay i got it
and under the gdpr almost every privacy
law out there has exemptions for law
enforcement for government usage for
consent based where you're opting in and
and so on so um yeah the the part that
is upsetting to me a bit is we had
people use it to save children and solve
crime there so i think it's a
misunderstanding of how uh our
intentions behind the technology uh
which are about to
you know help do good in the world yeah
but why would these guys have i mean i
get that i i don't
so one would have to speculate and say
a country is protecting its child
traffickers i don't think they are okay
are there any out there that do
they have to be the most corrupt
governments out there that are being
paid off but is that countries the size
of france italy australia i don't think
so i think it would be catastrophic like
australia came out
and said facial recognition from clear
video has been ordered to cease
collecting photos of australians from
the internet and it revealed police
it was revealed to police that some
states had trialed the technology
on wednesday the information privacy
commissioner determined clear vai had
breached the privacy of austrians by
collecting images of them online on
wednesday uh then it says and order the
company delete all the images of people
in australia within 90 days and not
collect anymore but clearly ai has stood
its ground saying it operates
legitimately in australia and tends to
appeal its decision
uh ai is a facial recognition service at
clemson build up enormous databases
okay so you see how some of these and by
the way this was i want to say november
21st around november of 2021 which is
like four or five months ago at the peak
of what was going on in australia okay
where some may even support what you
were doing because the world wanted to
know what the hell is going on in
australia some may say hey i want to
know what's going on australia they give
those guys a little bit of freedom
because there was two sides to it you
have to do this you have to do that you
can't get out if you don't take the shot
you can't get a job so you were playing
the role of a hero so is this a little
bit of these countries
do with themselves but they don't want
somebody else from the outside to do it
is there worry that maybe you are linked
to the us government where this
information is being leaked to them what
would be any of these countries a
concern we have to ask them but uh
because it's hard to read into their
motivations completely but these are
just the privacy agencies of these
countries right so
um they have their own agenda they have
their own belief in privacy and uh role
that they want to do you know
we hope that
we can engage in a debate and just help
educate because again a lot of these
laws do have exemptions for governmental
use they have exemptions for national
security and um and that's
you know our intention and i don't think
they want to be seen as people enabling
child traffickers these privacy
commissioners in these countries so our
work has been focused on countries who
do need us uh in the u.s has a lot of
need and most recently in ukraine uh
it's been used very successfully you
reached out to them yes
free of charge to use it did they accept
it did they yeah so about i think maybe
two or three weeks ago um
as a company we're seeing all the
horrific stuff that came out of ukraine
and
um
noticed that we thought that certain
situations where we could be helpful one
is helping identify
dead russian soldiers or ukrainian
soldiers
and so the technology can work on faces
that are deceased
another one is helping
in humanitarian refugee situations to
help verify identity if people don't
have identity cards with them and so we
wrote a letter and i tried every one i
knew in every way possible to get to
someone in the ukrainian government and
they reach back out to us and it's
being used in multiple agencies now and
we've i've gotten a lot of successful
emails coming back saying thank you so
much this is speeding things up in terms
of verifying people um
and also it's been used successfully to
id dead russian soldiers and even uh
find people who claim they're ukrainian
and actually are you know maybe russian
agents there so in this right that
that's i can see that of being
big value yeah claiming to be ukrainian
but they're russian so right there
one takes a picture sends it to them
they look it up they say no that guy's
not a
ukrainian he's russian boom he's playing
the game let's arrest him yeah i mean
that's that's some of the use cases that
uh we laid out in the letter and we've
heard amazing feedback and we're waiting
to hear more of it before we can talk
more about it but it's something that it
means a lot to us as a company and to me
personally i help set them up with
accounts and train them and you know
part of our value propositions we do
have about at least two billion photos
from russian social media right uh that
is also publicly available 20 billion
you said how many pictures you guys got
about two billion yeah oh got two i know
but total you have how many 20. out of
your 20 billion 2 billion is from russia
yeah so 10 of your images are from
russia yeah what percentage of the 20
billion is from u.s
i would say most of it is us-based yeah
wow but 10 russia that's massive yeah it
was is one of their you know social
media sites so again that's a use case
we didn't think of when we started but
it's been a great surprise and this is a
situation where things attend so in any
kind of war zone not knowing who someone
is
could lead to some kind of escalation so
it's a technology that allows people to
be more confident to verify you know
someone's identity and it can save lives
and so it's been a great honor there so
we you know go to places where there are
real um issues and able to help them and
we're very you know uh honored to do
that is there anybody else in the u.s
that does what you do
in your like your method of doing it
like clearview ai no so we're the only
company i think in the world that has
combined facial recognition plus uh
indexing the internet
as a two so only yeah
there was one that tried to do it before
you right banjo or something like that a
guy named damien i'm not sure i don't
think so maybe they had something else
there's a lot of different companies in
this space but you dig into it the
combination of those two and previous uh
facial recognition providers uh
you would if you were a law enforcement
you'd purchase it and then you would
load in your own bug shots you'd load on
your own data and then you'd search
against it so what if a crime happened
from someone out of state right then you
can't identify them what if the crime
happened somewhere overseas that child
molester case the guy was an argentine
citizen right so he's not even going to
be in a dmv database and children are
really interesting so once they arrest a
pedophile they have photos of kids they
don't know who the kids are they've been
abused they can find that child on a
public social media with their parents
and parents have no idea that kid has
been
abused so it it having a bigger data set
is is the is the thing that's allowed
them in law enforcement to say hey this
is the best thing we've ever seen and
that's why they're so passionate about
it um and as a company with the only two
to kind of combine those two we got
awarded a patent for it
and
it's it's really taken facial
recognition to the next level i i had a
a conversation with a security company
uh protection like executive security
company and these guys are very very
good at what they do want the best in
the marketplace and they'll they'll hire
a navy seal or former navy seal or a you
know former delta or whoever it is to
work with the price points change
depending on
the individual's experience but one of
the services they offered is say
say eight people at one point give you
death threat hypothetically say eight
people said you know what
we're gonna do this and we're gonna do
that they have software technology to
track where that person is going to be
traveling
this is working directly with the
government that's a fee it's not cheap
it's a lot of money you spend with them
but that is of high value for somebody
who is out there on this public figure
to say
i got these seven people who said xyz
now i know when they're in you know
landing in fort lauderdale a little bit
increasing a protection hey these next
weeks that guys over here so i can see
value in that
i i keep going back on thinking what the
next level of what you're doing today
will be there's always a next level what
you do what you're doing right now if
somebody looks in and say okay this
makes sense where you're taking you know
where you're at by the way out of your
3100 agencies that you work in are all
of them us and canada only
uh they're mainly us um and then yeah
yeah is there any other countries that
are with you now or is it just us and
canada it's us no canada okay ukraine um
and that's all we have to announce on
okay other countries got it so uh so
you you can do you have a bylaw or a
like a like a
commitment to the
audience that these are multiple
countries that we will not do business
with are there any countries that you
wouldn't take any check from them to do
business with absolutely and i've said
this before publicly you know china
russia any countries that are adverse
united states um you know we're open to
selling it to any kind of democratically
run country because our software is
built with that in mind right these
after the fact investigations is very
suited towards uh democratic kind of
countries and that kind of judicial
process iran would be out of it yeah
anything that's sanctioned or partially
sanctioned by the us uh we wouldn't do
and so yeah
got it so so you said russia china iran
uh you probably had north korea to that
list as well and a few other
countries that are out there that's a
those are all definite no's right so
would would the u.s government have any
problem with what you're doing
would they at all say something like you
know what clearview ai
um
you know you're you're small when you
have 10 employees you had a technology
we're doing it's awesome you guys had a
you know billion images two million
images yeah 20 billion images you're now
helping governments like ukraine you're
not helping xyz type of organizations
you're the only one in the world it's
not like there's 50 of you out there
you're the only one in the world that's
doing what they're doing don't you think
that whole only one in the world kind of
scares the crap out of the government
that has no control over some company
that's the only one in the world where
time magazine calls it the top 100
influential companies out there
yeah well they're a customer right so we
always collaborate with them on at the
state level though not at the federal at
the federal level at the federal level
fbi homeland security etc is also with
you guys yeah there's a lot of uh you
know federal agencies who use it for you
know crimes the government's really big
there's different arms of the government
you have congress you have president you
have the white house then you have
these agencies and you have all that
kind of stuff so
we have a lot of support
within the us government the government
accountability office came out with a
report on
all facial recognition used in the
federal government guidelines on how to
procure it responsibly right how to use
it what kind of use cases all that kind
of stuff so we've seen adoption there
and um
and we we're really honored to help out
two things here that concerns one is
elon musk i'm sure you know you know
what his position is with with this he's
said this for many many times he said
this in 18. uh he fears a.i more than
anybody else does like the way he says
you know you guys are worried about this
there's nothing to be worried about
worry about ai speaking out of my team
2014 musk uh called ai humanity biggest
existential threat and compared it to
summoning the demon ai scientists at
oxford and uc berkeley luminaries like
stephen alkin and
many of the researchers publishing
groundbreaking results agree with musk
that ai could be very dangerous
they are concerned that we're eagerly
working toward developing power a
powerful ass system that we might be
we might do so under conditions that are
ripe for dangerous mistakes as ai gets
probably much smarter than humans the
relative intelligence ratio is probably
similar to that between a person and a
cat maybe bigger i this is ilan saying
this i do think we need to be very
careful about the advancement of ai
there's a very strong concentration of
ai power especially at google deep mind
and i have very high regard for larry
page and dennis
hasabis but i do think there's value to
some independent oversight what do you
say about what elon's thoughts are on
artificial intelligence well i think
elon musk is a great man you know he's
invented a lot of stuff so
um and he's an amazing entrepreneur as
well he's got a ton of written
determination i think he's spot on about
quite a few things right we're open to
regulation we think regulation would be
good
if there are laws saying that for
example these data sets should only be
used for law enforcement that shouldn't
be used for you know all these other use
cases i think that would help
a lot of the general public
come to more ease around the technology
if there was you know some guidelines
and government regulation and oversight
on facial recognition technology i think
that ai has continuously surprised me on
how much better and accurate it has
gotten
my philosophy at the end of the day is
to always have a human in the loop right
we want tools to serve us and the way we
build the technology is you know when
you do the search and you find the image
you click the link you try and find the
name and then you continue your
investigation
it's helping make people who do their
jobs more efficient and better at their
jobs
technology that does that
is awesome right technology that uh what
i think i get a little worried about is
things around automated decision making
right and things like that uh can you
tell me more so automated decision
making um you know could be if something
is really high um
uh
for example a system that could
you know do the identification and then
say all right automatically go arrest
that person right there's no human there
making a judgment machines and ai just
can do what humans do
on a repetitive basis in a better way
so that's why machines are really good
at like facial recognition they're
really good at searching the internet
they're good at those kind of things but
they're not good at making certain
judgments right or uh
you know human relations and things like
that so
machines are good at certain things
but humans are a lot better at still a
lot of things and as long as humans are
in charge right that
you have
a functioning government you have rule
of law all those kind of things i see
this as a technology that just makes
humans better at what they do and that's
how i think a lot of ai should be
deployed i don't think people want to
live in a
world like skynet
no i don't think i don't think they do i
think
we like freedom
i think the idea of having somebody
uh watch us you know like
i don't know who we had on here
uh we had somebody on here saying the
power of having things being recorded
because you get to see like you know the
human uh what do you call it citizen
journalism yeah is one of the best
things that happened where
this
gave
everybody a form of accountability right
this has become one of the most powerful
weapons where we get to see videos and
say oh that's not cool what you just did
right there got it anybody
with common sense can say
that was not acceptable just took place
right there right yeah okay if we don't
have this we can't judge it for
ourselves right
the concern is what you just said right
now which is what was the word use
automated decision making yeah automated
decision making where a computer can
tell us this guy is about to commit a
crime this guy needs to be arrested
uh uh we don't want to go in that
direction you still need the human touch
where we're not just going to rely 100
solely on technology to make decisions
for us especially vigorous decisions
like when you talk about the judicial
process there have been talks or like
hey can you do automated decision making
on sentencing and things like that i
don't think that's a good idea i think
there always should be a human judge
and jury and all that kind of stuff when
it comes to making decisions because
it's a human world we live in when you
start did you think this thing was going
to get this public with the new york
times cover story did you think that was
going to happen or no no i didn't do
that
you thought this was just
did you have any expectation for this
thing to be
where it's at right now where you're
helping out governments like ukraine
doing what they're doing did you expect
it to be this big this quick um
it depends on what year you ask in 2019
when we gave it to law enforcement we
knew it was a really big deal because it
was growing so quickly we're growing at
like 20 30 month on month
on new signups and revenue and all these
things so we knew it was a big deal we
know when
people would use it we would see their
reactions and it would go through like
wow that actually works and then they
would talk about concerns just like we
would do and then we'd show them here
are examples of cases that are solved
and i think once they saw that it was
used for after the fact investigations
and you know child crimes people became
a lot you know more comfortable so i saw
that on an individual basis before
the first story came out but when the
first story came out it was really
intense i mean we only had 10 people
people think we're some massive mega
corporation um and we're lucky to
survive and is it public how much money
you guys have raised i know peter feels
a part of it
totally we've raised 38.5 publicly and
million dollars yeah and uh we have a
whole wide range of investors
that have backed us so family offices
institutional investors uh and you know
some seed funds as well
so i mean we're very grateful for all
our support
and
yeah it's been a wild ride
yeah it's definitely
you know
as a kid who grew up in a christian
environment okay in iran which you
couldn't be and i was an atheist until i
was 25 years old
this whole concept about god's watching
you watching everything you do you know
how parents put that fear in there and
they would say the famous lion mommy may
not know what you did but god does
you know
dad may not know what you're doing god's
watching you okay
and then you'll learn about free will
which free will is what the ability to
do whatever i want to do and then you
know if i commit a crime guess what i go
to jail for it but if i break something
i'm going to suffer some consequences
but the free will is there
the concern becomes we are more and more
going towards
the government wanting to be more
powerful than god where the free will is
taken out
um
that's a little concerning where i don't
have the ability to make a decision for
myself because of an opinion you gave
that may influence me in a way and i'm
not talking about your world i'm talking
more
uh
what happened during covet specifically
how censorship was at a high and yeah
this person's being censored that person
is being censored you saw the other day
with babylon b
put a story out there and twitter
wouldn't uh reinstate you know bring
them back up and reactivate them
and babylon beast's founder him and i
were communicating over the weekend
they stuck to the ground and we said
we're not doing it and now they're not
on twitter but
harmony's on twitter a lot of putin's
still on twitter and they're doing what
they're doing to the world so i think
the concern with a lot of technologies
like yourself again i wish
my goal today was to have two cia agents
here with us okay to have a conversation
maybe
maybe we'll do that next time but to
kind of get them because
one of them was all in for what you're
doing
when i tell you all in 100 all in for
what you're doing he says believe me
america needs what those guys are
working on okay there's only a few
things that they have to be careful with
he kind of talked about the automated
decision making he just didn't use those
words he explained in a different way
the other one said
that uh uh he believes we're going in
this direction whether we like it or not
it's just who's in charge and running
this okay so icity and i talked and i
said okay nice guy they don't watch any
tv till 14 reader gaming coder that's
what you did later on you built games
you did what you you're kind of messing
around with certain things you didn't
like authority telling you what to do
you kind of are the guy that if somebody
tells you can't do it you do do it so
i'm assuming you're probably the guy the
more these lawsuits you get in a weird
way i feel you get more excited you're
like come on down you know push us more
try to silence us
hosting the world's first ever lawyer
appreciation day yeah in june in new
york city so you are yeah really that's
why i told our lawyers it's like look
you know
we're going to do this for you and
they've never had it before and they
said you know your appreciation day
oh my god
i've never heard of lawyer appreciation
day they need to have them they but for
me there are some of the best in their
field i get to learn from them i never
had to deal with lawyers on this level
but now
it's really interesting well i'm sure
they love you man that's like a big
endorsement for lawyers because
we aren't necessary yeah but uh like
floyd abrams for example he's um very
he's famous for defending the new york
times in the pentagon papers case a very
strong first amendment case against the
government he's one of our lawyers right
he took on our case because he feels
that like this is public information it
should be out used by anybody would you
want to live in a world where any of
these companies can send a cease and
desist like facebook google and they
dictate what's in the public square i
don't think that's the kind of the right
world there uh so um yeah we're hosting
the world's first ever lawyer
appreciation day it's gonna be a lot of
fun we have a red carpet photos i know
your appreciation day well i think
you're gonna need the best lawyers and i
think you're gonna need to
keep lawyered up for a long time to do
what you're doing because
we attract the best people in each field
but anyway back to what you were saying
about you know who's uh running things
and i i your censorship issue is a big
issue right and i think that these
companies have more and more power over
time you have twitter you have facebook
and they've been say more powerful than
a newspaper because they can
take someone's account away or you know
take information off for whatever reason
they want but i think in a lot of ways
the system we're working in is evolving
right it learns from new information and
that it could be around now a lot of
these uh mandates found mosques and code
would have been lifted because you know
a lot of politicians look at re-election
and they say okay most people don't want
to have these on all the time
so um
i think we're coming out a lot of the
covert crisis and things that happened
there so we what's great about america
it's a very dynamic place right and the
system that's set up with the
judiciary and the congress and the
executive branch it there's a lot of
balance of power and so things do swing
back and forth and i think that's what
makes it great because you do have you
know it takes the best out of its
population
and turns them into like great
entrepreneurs and things like that so i
think it's still a special place and
there's always going to be concerns
about those things especially around
censorship it's a big deal or you know
things that
uh could be over the top from you know
the executive branch but you know things
go back and forth and um and we're here
we're still talking and you know your
show's still in the air i'm still
allowed to be here it is
the the last thing before we wrap up is
the business model per search
is that the business model or is it a
monthly membership you give to the
agency it's like a yearly membership so
we charge on a yearly basis how many
agents or
investigators you want to have access to
it we encourage them to have a facial
recognition policy we put them through
training um and we make sure there's an
admin to make to see that it's being
used for the right stuff so they can
turn off uh accounts so if you've got it
so there's an admin say i got 50 people
that are tracking each of these i'm
paying for each of the users but the
admin if i'm tracking to see what this
guy is searching for
i can turn them off or turn them on and
give it give the user to somebody else
and give it an annual membership that's
the model that's basically the model
this certain custom projects we do
and things like that but it's basically
a sas model what what's the max what's
the capacity like what percentage of
reach do you have like if you were to
say
we can grow and scale to xyz for
somebody that would be interested from
the investor standpoint what is the
upside of how big you guys can get so um
in terms of governmental uh market cap
and things like that tam
yeah it's quite large if you look at you
know government contractors can be a
really big business or even look at
lexisnexis the thompson reuters clear
they're investigative tools i think they
do 400 500 million a year
um yeah so that's just kind of the
baseline uh but we think it could be a
lot larger uh overall
not just with government but there are
things where there's opt-in cases for
identity verification or airport example
you mentioned so i think facial
recognition will be transformative
technology across a lot of other
industries
where it enhances safety
and
and security and that's what it really
is at the end of the day if anyone to
take away from this is you know it's a
security technology and it's been used
effectively very effectively so far to
solve crimes i'll give you the final
thoughts to
uh
to closing message here to the
non-believer
uh to the critics out there who
uh uh uh don't feel as optimistic about
what you guys are doing as maybe these
3100 agencies that are using to the
people out there that understand that
this is a great tool to catch that
individual what he did with the
six-year-old where somebody in the
background his face was there and they
recognized and they wanted caught him
he's doing 35 years in jail
that's great that that man was caught we
want every one of those people to be
caught
but uh
you know the concern of possibly someone
who hasn't committed a crime being held
accountable for something they didn't do
in an organization or an institution you
know crossing the power line you know
and power
that they have to use this as a way of
abusing people again going back to the
you know the big brothers wet dream
essentially of having control over the
people 1984 right
what would you say to the people there
that are not as optimistic about this
final thoughts well i'd say the first
thing is
me personally as long as i run this
company i only want it to be used for
good things
i want to
have it used to solving crimes and not
in any way that violates anyone's human
rights or being misused and that's
really important to me and it's just
something that personally you know we
have really good intentions and we want
the highest and the best use of the
technology and um we're always looking
at every day on how to protect the
downside so to people who don't quite
believe in the technology i mean a lot
of the critics early on said it was
inaccurate is biased i think a lot of
that's now in the past and it's how we
use facial recognition and technology
and we're open to regulation we want
this to be a debate we want to hear the
other side we hear a lot of the concerns
we when we do we try and integrate into
our software better auditing and things
like that so we're always open uh
to that discussion and i think you know
two three years into the technology um
we've seen no wrongful arrest due to
to clear uai and yeah i just want people
to know that we have the best intentions
because it's
you know my life's work that's all i
think about that's all i work on and the
last thing i would want is for this to
end up hurting somebody and we've seen
it help a lot of people um and that
would be you know heartbreaking to me
wow appreciate that appreciate you for
coming out and thanks patrick answering
a lot of these questions and uh you know
for folks out there that want to know
more about clearview ei you are not
going to have a hard time finding it
it's all over the place uh we wish you
nothing but the best man i hope you stay
in the right place of wanting to do the
right thing for the people and not on
the other side and hopefully this
organization does good things in the
future continues to do good things
thanks patrick any time really
appreciate it take care all right folks
uh
this is uh the interview that we did
with juan in regards to cleveland
comment below and give us your thoughts
good bad what are you thinking i want to
hear from you
you